hello this is the metamorphosis of the
cube I'm Professor Eric domain in Cecil
at MIT and this is joint work with
martin domain and olivia joseph work and
arena pachenko and we're looking here at
different foldings and unfoldings of
surfaces in 3d here we have our friend
the cube and a familiar unfolding of the
cube called the cross unfolding and it
turns out that if you change the creases
in the cross and fold it up a different
way you can make all sorts of different
convex polyhedra here we have a very
simple one a flat doubly covered
quadrilateral but all the others are
going to be non flat we saw the cube got
the quadrilateral the next one is a
Penta he'd run five sides and we form
exactly the surface of this bilaterally
symmetric Penta he'd run on the other
hand if we change the creases in this
way then we get a tetrahedron this is my
favorite because the little tab fits
exactly into the pocket exactly the
surface of that tetrahedra not a regular
tetrahedron but I tetrahedron
nonetheless
and finally if we change the creases in
this way we get an octahedron and all of
these polyhedra are computed
automatically with an algorithm that
given a flat shape tells you all of the
different convex polyhedra that it can
glue up into so here we had five
different shapes the cube the
quadrilateral the Penta hydron the
tetrahedron and the octahedron but for
different polygons you get different 3d
shapes just to give you an idea of the
range of unfolding unfolding is a lot
harder if I give you a 3d surface you
cut it up and try to unfold it when does
it overlap is a big question that was an
example of a non overlapping unfolding
there's quite a variety in what you can
do here's a particularly fun unfolding
we call the stoplight unfolding of the
cube looks like a stoplight and here's
one example of another 3d convex
polyhedron you can fold it up into which
we call the spaceship for technical
reasons and again the algorithm
automatically computes all the different
3d convex polyhedra you can glue that
flat shape into here we go back to the
cube and this is ongoing research in
computational geometry